a patient walks into my office expecting
a prescription for an antibiotic but I
don't write one let's talk about what
happens on this week's Wednesday checkup
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's set the scene here we have a 38
year old female that comes in with a
chief complaint of upper respiratory
symptoms it's been going on for a period
of two to three days and her main
complaints come from fatigue sore throat
dry cough and runny nose a little bit of
background on the patient she has two
children is currently married and has a
very stressful job probably the most
important part of the story is that she
has a vacation coming up in 11 days and
she's worried that this infection may
interfere with those plans normal vital
signs no fever
perdón positives inflamed nostrils
inflamed throat / negatives no exudates
on the tonsils which means those nasty
little white plaques that you sometimes
see clear lungs no abdominal pain no
rashes and very importantly no swollen
lymph nodes at this point I had a very
strong suspicion that my patient has a
viral illness I don't even know which
viral illness but it doesn't make much
of a difference because it doesn't
change my management viruses are treated
in the same manner we give supportive
care to the patient treat their symptoms
make sure they get enough rest hydration
in order for their own bodies
to fight off those infections when I
told the patient about my diagnosis she
met it with hesitation and wanted to
know if she was gonna get a prescription
for antibiotics I explained to her that
antibiotics don't work on viral
conditions like the one that I suspect
that she was having I had to explain to
her that weighing the risks for his
benefits here I still thought that not
using antibiotics was the right move she
put her trust in me and told me that she
would call me over the weekend if any
problems were to arise come Sunday two
days later the patient calls my office
and lets me know that she's not getting
better and she's wondering if she should
go to an urgent care facility I talked
to her about her symptoms it just to me
seems like her viral illness still
hasn't improved because she hasn't
reached that day six day seven where we
usually see a turnaround and I told her
that it was in her best interest to
stick with the symptom management treat
herself with rest height
with green tea and honey and stick
through it and give me a call in two
days surprise surprise patient calls me
in two days
lets me know that she's feeling a lot
better and turned around on day six all
her symptoms pretty much resolved she
did let me know that on Sunday she ended
up going to an urgent care facility and
got a rapid strep test done which came
up negative as we initially thought so
she was very grateful that we didn't
unnecessarily treat her with antibiotics
and it was a good result and I thought
it was important to talk about this
result because it's a very common
situation where doctors either over
prescribed antibiotics or doctors don't
prescribe an antibiotic and then
patients get really upset about it so
let's talk about that the situation of a
patient coming in and requesting
antibiotics when they're not actually
needed or indicated happens quite often
and I want to start off by telling you
why doctors should not be prescribing
antibiotics unnecessarily reason number
one resistance antibiotics work against
certain bacteria that are not resistant
to them however when you give patients
antibiotics over and over again you
create a type of bacteria known as a
super bug which actually becomes
resistant to that antibiotic and
therefore an antibiotic becomes useless
and there's only so many antibiotics out
there where we can actually run out of
antibiotics to give a patient because
they have such a multi drug resistant
bacterial infection second adverse
reactions I'm talking about allergic
reactions where the throat closes up
rashes diarrhea and infection known as
Clostridium difficile where you kill all
the good bacteria in your bowels so that
this bad bacteria grows and Fester's and
you have the worst bacteria ever three
antibiotics don't work against viruses I
know many people say well as soon as I
got the antibiotic I felt better you
would have felt better without the
antibiotic in fact when we treat a strep
throat with antibiotics we're not even
really treating the strep throat it
would get better on its own the reason
we give antibiotics here is to prevent
the complications of strep throat like
rheumatic fever kidney issues let that
sink in for a moment
and finally for
the costs why would you spend money on
antibiotics when you have a virus
they're not even gonna be helping you
and possibly harming you the art of
medicine is about balancing the risks
versus benefits to be in your favor now
let's move on and talk about what
pressures doctors face to prescribe
antibiotics even though they may not be
the appropriate choice of treatment
first patient requests like we had in my
story a patient comes in and requests
firmly and antibiotics you can discuss
very clearly with them why you think an
antibiotic isn't the optimal choice you
can explain the risks the benefits and
the patient can still request antibiotic
so you go ahead and right one the second
connects very closely with the first and
it's these doctor review sites like
sockdoc Yelp and so forth where if a
patient doesn't get the treatment they
expected to get they can leave a nasty
review that can truly hurt your own
business think about it if I open my own
practice and I'm trying to establish
myself and have a good name and give
quality service and not give unnecessary
antibiotics but a patient really wanted
them they leave me a bad review that can
really hurt my business 3 is something
you may not have heard of it's c/y a
medicine cover your butt medicine
essentially what doctors are doing is
that they're afraid that if you don't
prescribe antibiotics for a patient and
they actually do have a bacterial
infection they get worse they may be
held liable through a lawsuit and that's
scary stuff for a doctor you don't want
to be sued by a patient especially in
the age we live in where it seems
everybody's just suing everybody all the
time
fourth is patient satisfaction if a
patient pays to go to the doctor's visit
and leaves with no prescription and
instead leaves with advice to drink
green tea honey and hydrate they feel
like they didn't get a lot out of the
visit and can leave very unhappy but we
have to remember the reason we pay for a
doctor's visit is not to buy a
prescription it's to consult a doctor on
their medical opinion as to what's going
on with you and what is the best
treatment option to solve that problem
please don't think i'm anti antibiotics
antibiotics are a life-saving drug and
when appropriate is so important to give
in fact if someone has a viral infection
they become more susceptible to getting
a bacterial infection on top of it so
that if you initially have symptoms of a
viral illness that suddenly get worse
you may need antibiotics I'm definitely
for antibiotics but I'm for responsible
use of antibiotics we covered
antibiotics and I told you my story but
I also happen to go to my p.o box today
and picked up some packages Pennsylvania
Oh
oh my god why is everyone sending these
shirts it's a new Finland with a little
heartbeat bear what do you think about
this shirt what do you think California
San Diego oh my gosh chest compressions
chest compressions Cynthia thank you so
much for this shirt if you don't start
making merch soon I swear to god I'm
sorry I'm working with the trademark
attorney there's so much nonsense when
it comes to making your own merch I'm a
doctor I have no idea what I'm doing
but I promise there's gonna be merged
sued Japan Oh a little Japanese Kit Kat
action Kit Kat Easter eggs white
chocolate cake that thank you
my Japanese friend this is from Denmark
look at this look at these candies look
at these candies this is misleading the
obesity epidemic but I'm gonna love it
thank you so much
safeguard your family's health with a
mild laxative health away products from
1950 whoa is this like this looks
genuine this is like an artifact
Caroline this is amazing I'm gonna save
this I don't even want to show you guys
what this is this is weird health
products from the 50s this one's your
major
Oh our daily bread because everybody
needs a carb bear balm check good first
aid kit do not open unless emergency
that's so sweet
you guys need to watch my video that I
did with my nephew Ari where we did a
disgusting science experiment so click
here for that bad boy and as always stay
happy and healthy